[موسيقى]
شراره المعارك في السودان منتصف الشهر
الماضي بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع لم تتوقف التحذيرات من امكانيه
اتساع نطاقها ورقعتها الى مناطق اخرى داخل
البلد وربما خارجه وهي مناطق معروفه
بهاشاشتها الامنيه وبيئتها الخصبه
للنزاعات هذا ما حمل العديد من الاطراف
العربيه والافريقيه والدوليه الى المسارعه
بتقديم مبادرات تدعو الى وقف اطلاق النار
وتناشد اطراف الصراع الجلوس الى طاوله
التفاوض حقنا للدماغ وحفاظا على الامن
والاستقرار فما هي فرص نجاح هذه المبادرات
في ظل تباين المواقف بين الجيش بين الجيش
والدعم السريع وما طبيعه الحلول التي يمكن
التوصل اليها بين طرفين بعد كل ما جرى
اهلا بكم في هذه الحلقه من سيناريوه
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم كثيره هي المبادرات التي
تسعى الى تطبيق الازمه السودانيه ووقف
الاشتباكات المتواصله منذ نحو ثلاثه
اسابيع في العاصمه الخرطوم وولايات اخرى
عن هذه المبادرات وفرص نجاحها او نجاح اي
منها على الاقل في اكتساب قوه دفع كافيه
لتحقيق بعض التقدم يسعدنا ان يكون معنا
هنا في الاستوديو والكاتب والمحلل السياسي
السوداني ضياء الدين بلال من باريس الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السوداني محمد تورشين ومن
واشنطن مايكل كارني السفيره الامريكيه
السابق لدى السودان وسيشارك معنا ايضا في
جزء من هذه الحلقه من جيبوتي المتحدث باسم
السكرتيره التنفيذي للايجاد نور محمود شيخ
يستمر القتال في السودان رغم الهدن التي
لا تكاد تبدا حتى تتوقف ما ينذر باتساع
دائره الصراع وربما امتداده الى مناطق
اخرى داخل السودان او خارجه ما يزيد
الاوضاع تعقيدا ورغم اعلان الاطراف
المتصارعه موافقتها المبدئيه على
المبادرات المطروحه فان التصعيد الميدانيه
المتواصل وتباعد المواقف والاصرار على
تحقيق مكاسب عسكريه قبل الجلوس المحتمل
الى طاوله المفاوضات كلها مؤشرات على ان
المخرج من المازق الحالي ومن دوامه
الاقتتال قد لا يكون وشيكا في المدى
القريب على الاقل لكن دخول الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن على خط الازمه ودعوته
الى وقف دائما لاطلاق النار واصداره امرا
تنفيذيا بفرض عقوبات على من سماهم
المسؤولين عن تهديد السلام وتقويد
الانتقال الديمقراطي في السودان يعتبر
نقطه تحولا قد تكون حاسمه في المقاربه
الامريكيه لهذا الصراع تقري فوزي بشرى
[موسيقى]
من هنا بدا كل شيء بدات الظاهره التي
سيدخل معها السودان اكثر ايامه عنفا
واضطرابا
[موسيقى]
في خلال اسبوعين
الدنيا كانت خريف قال لي حاضر
[موسيقى]
ما جاب 5000 بس جاب 6000
انها القوه التي تكونت من بضع عشرات ثم
اصبحت بضع مئات يقودها الشاب العشريني
محمد حمدان دقلو حميدتي في اقليم دارفور
الذي لم يعرف السلام طيله سنوات التسعينات
الاولى من هذا القرن نادر كان في ليبيا من
تلك النواه الميليشياويه سينمو الدعم
السريع مستغلا تناقضات السياسه والعسكريه
السودانيه ادمان حكم الرئيس عمر البشير
وليحقق طفرته الكبرى بعد الثوره التي انهت
حكمه في عام 2019 انه النمو الذي كان يجري
تحت بصر الجميع حتى اصبحت قوات الدعم
السريع جيشا ضخما ينظر اليه على انه اصبح
مهددا لكيان الدوله السودانيه
بعد الثوره لم يعد الفريق حميدتي قائدا
عسكريا مدخرا لقمع الاضطرابات والتمردات
لقد خرج على النص الذي كتبه البشير يوم
كان لا يعدوه بجمله زائده
سيصير حبيبتي نائبا برئيس المجلس العسكري
فلما قامت اول حكومه مدنيه برئاسه عبد
الله حمدوك كان حميدتي قد اتخذ موقعه
نائبا لرئيس مجلس السياده يشارك حميدتي
فيما سمته القوى المدنيه منقلاب البرهان
عليها في الخامس والعشرين من اكتوبر عام
2021 ثم سريعا يمقض يده من ذلك الذي سمته
القوه المدنيه بالانقلاب ويتبرا مما
اعتبره خطا لقد تحولت قوه الدعم السريع
الى راس مال سياسي يتزايد بازدياد توسعها
ولم يعد معها حميتي قوه عسكريه وحسب بل
اصبح في سياق صيروره تطوريه متعدده
الطفرات قدم خلالها نفسه على انه الراعي
الرسمي للمشروع الديمقراطي في السودان
والحامي له بقواته وكان قد اشترط لدمج تلك
القوات في الجيش امدا زمنيا مدته 10 سنوات
وهو ما رتضه قاده الجيش
ويبدو انه لم يكن من الحرب بد بعد ان بلغ
التناقضات العسكريه والسياسه السودانيه
حدها النهائي انه المازق الماساوي الذي
انتهى اليه السودان وكشف بتكاليفه الباهظه
تشوهات الدوله السودانيه
وتواطؤ نخبتها العسكريه والسياسيه على
التعامل عن حيثيات ما كانت لتؤدي الى غير
الذي ادت اليه يقول سودانيون ما المخرج من
الوضع الراهن المطروح امام الحكومه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع مبادرتان
امريكيه سعوديه وهذه المبادره تدعو الى
تحقيق هدنه تتطور الى وقف لاطلاق النار
يحقق سرعه الاستجابه للحاجات الانسانيه
لملايين السودانيين ثم يفضي الى محادثات
بين الطرفين خاصه وقد هاتف بشانها وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي والسعودي كلا من
البرهان قائد الجيش
قائد قوات الدعم السريع ثم هناك مبادره
اخرى تقف وراءها منظمه الايجاد وهي ايضا
تدعو الى الالتزام بهدنه يعقبها ارسال
مبعوثين يمثلان القوات المتقاتله في
الخرطوم للدخول في حوار بينهما في جوبا
عاصمه جنوب السودان
واياما كانت وجاحه هذه المبادره او تلك
فان سؤالا اشكاليا سيواجه اصحاب المبادرات
بالقدر نفسه الذي سيواجه به اطراف الصراع
وهو التفاوض حول ماذا
لزم الجيش السوداني موقفا واحدا فرق فيه
بين امرين وهما امكانيه الالتزام بالغدن
لاسباب انسانيه اما الموقف الاخر فهو
تاكيده انه لا يمكن الجلوس مع قوات متمرده
على الدوله وان خياراته هي قمع التمرد اما
باستسلامه او بالقضاء عليه اما الفريق
محمد حمدان قائد الدعم السريع فيقول انه
يحارب من اجل استعاده المسار الديمقراطي
الذي قطع الطريق عليه انقلابيون وصفهم
بالاسلاميين الراديكاليين وانه سيلاحق
البرهان لتقديمه للمحاكمه لغدره بالمشروع
الديمقراطي وهو زعم قد يجد له مؤيدين من
القوه السياسيه في الداخل كما قد يجد صدى
له في الدوائر الغربيه ان لم يكن قد وجد
هل ستملك المبادرات والساعون بها القدره
على رد الازمه الى اصلها
فالفيل الذي يرى في الغرفه هو وجود قوه
عسكريه يقول الجيش انها تمردت عليه وهددت
كيان البلاد وسلامتها وتقول هي من جانبها
انها تحمي التحول الديمقراطي وتحقيق الحكم
المدني هنا ستكون معضله اصحاب المبادرات
اذا خاضوا فيما يعنيه عمليا وجود دوله
بجيشين وفي معنى ان يتحقق تحول ديمقراطي
في كنف البنادق البنادق التي يتصل نسبها
بانظمه الله علاقه لها بالديمقراطيه يقول
الذين يردون وقائع السودان الى نظائرها في
المنطقه العربيه والراجح لدى كثيرين ان
السودان بعد الحرب لن يكون كما كان قبلها
لا في عسكريته ولا في سياسته
سيد ضياء الدين بلال اهلا وسهلا بك
التطور الاخير والمهم في الموضوع السوداني
دخول الرئيس الامريكي بايدن عبر رسالته
الى رئيس مجلس النواب وحديث قوي عن
الموضوع السوداني واعتباره اكثر من ذلك
عتاب اعتباره تهديد للامن القومي الامريكي
ما يجري هل هذه التصريحات او هذا الكلام
بالاحرى يمكن ان يشكل ضغط لايجاد تسويه في
القريب لا اعتقد ذلك اعتقد ان التداعيات
الميدان هي التي ستتحكم معظم هذه
التهديدات لن تؤثر على الاقل الان هنالك
معادلات قوه عسكريه لم لم تصل الى نهايات
بعد خاصه فيما يتعلق بسيطره دعم السريع
على بعض المقاهر الاساسيه منها القصر
الجمهوري لا يستطيع الجيش ان يجلس للتفاوض
والدعم السريع يسيطر على القصر الجمهوري
اما المجال بتاع تحديد بالعقوبات هذه طريق
الامريكيه هي خمس رؤساء السابقين
صدرت مثل هذه
القرارات العق ولكنها للاسف لم تكن عقابات
عقاب ذكي كان عقاب يستهدف الدوله اكثر من
من
الحاكمين
حددت شخصيات مسؤوله عن كذا بمعنى محدوده
هذا هو تغيير هذا هو تغيير ولكن انه سيؤثر
الان خاصه الصراع ليس صراع اشخاص
الدافعيه الخاصه بالنسبه للجيش الدافعيه
مؤسسيه ليست متمثله في رغبه خاصه بالنسبه
للبرهان لخوض هذه الحرب البرهان
طر للدخول في هذه الحرب بدفع من المؤسسه
العسكريه التي كانت تشعر بالغب وتشعر
بتدخلات الدعم السريع حتى في التعيينات
الخاصه بالجيش فبالتالي هنالك تراكم
لمرارات وتراكم
لبعض
السعرات القديمه فيما يتعلق باستفزاز
الجيش والتقليل من حجمه ولكن اسمح لي من
الصعب سواء بالنسبه لحميدتي او البرهان
الا ياخذ
اعتبار كلام بين الاخير لان كلا منهما
مهما كانت مالات الحرب
يسعى الى ان يبني جسور معينه مع الولايات
المتحده مع حلفاء الولايات المتحده في
المنطقه مع اسرائيل وبالتالي لا يستطيع ان
يتجاهل هذا الكلام وكانه لم يكن هذا ما
بعد الانتهاء المعادلات الحرب لا اعتقد ان
قبل ذلك يمكن الاعتبارات السياسيه الان لا
تفرض منطقه ولا قوه على اطراف الصناعه
الاطراف الصراع تستمع فقط لاصوات الرصاص
تنظر فقط لموقعها العسكري من يكن يده
العليا في هذه المعادله حتى حينما يتم
الجلوس على طاولات التفاوض يستطيع ان يحقر
مكاسب اعتقد ان ذلك هو الذي يستغرق
البرهان ويستغرق ويستغرق المؤسسات كذلك
اذا كان خاصه فيما يتعلق بالجيش لم يعد
الامر فيما يتعلق بالاستمرار في هذه الحرب
او الدخول في
مفاوضات امر خاص بالبرهان كرئيس المجلس
السيادي او كرئيس للجيش هذا المؤسسه اصبحت
هيئه القياده العسكريه في الجيش هي التي
تتحكم في مالات هذه الاوضاع ولا اعتقد ان
هيئه القياده وهي ترى هذا التدمير وترى
اشياء كثيره جدا
مستفزه للمكونه العسكري
وللمواطنين ان تستجيب لهذه التحديدات في
هذا الوقت تحديدا نعم لنسال سفير
عما اذا كان كلام الرئيس جو بايدن الاخير
يمكن ان يؤثر في المعادله الحاليه في
السودان رغم ما يقوله ضيفنا الان في
الاستوديو بان الكلمه ستكون للميدان
وللرصاص
اعتقد ان ذلك يضيف
ضغوطات على حمايه والبرهان
وزملائهما الذين يدعمون القتال في السودان
اليوم
ولكن اصل المساله فيما يخص العقوبات هي
دعم العقوبات من قبل الاسره الدوليه او
معظمها قدر الامكان والى ذلك اريد ان ارى
ما هي رده الفعل على تفويض الرئيس
لاستخدام العقوبات
ردت فعل الخليج
ودول الجاره للسودان
وايضا القوى الاوروبيه المهتمه هل تتوقع
ان تكون هذه العقوبات على اشخاص محددين
على عكس العقوبات التي طالت السودان في
السابق مع عمر البشير
حسنا هذا سيعتمد على الفتره التاليه هذا
تفويض فحسب ما من احد سمي ثمه
فئاته وثم خانات ترتبط باقتراف بعض
الاشخاص هذا وذاك واغتصابنا او هناك
وانتهاكات هنا او هناك ولكن لم يسمى احد
بعد هناك ضغوطات يمكن ان تفرض على اولئك
الذين يمكنهم ان يفكروا انهم سيسمون
ويوضعون على هذه اللائحه هذا التلويح
بالعقوبات سيد محمد تورشين هل تتوقع ان
يلعب دورا في على الاقل على الاقل في
تخفيف معارضه كل من البرهان او المؤسسه
العسكريه
وحميتي لامكانيه الوصول الى تسويه ما
في البدء لك التحيه ولكل الساده المشاهدين
وضيوفك الكرامه الاولى استطاعت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بالتلويح بسلاح
العقوبات ان اجبر الطرفين بالتوصل الى هدى
متعلقه بوقت اطلاق النار ففي هذا الاطار
انا في تقديري طرفه الصرع الجيش السوداني
وكذلك قوه الدعم السريع هتعمل بشكل او
باخر على محاوله استجابه ولو كانت استجابه
نظريه على قرار ما يحدث فيما يتعلق بالهدن
وفعليا ستمضي قدما فيما يتعلق بالحسم
العسكري لان كل طرف الان ومنذ اندلاع هذه
المواجهات يقرر بان لابد ان يكون الحسم
حتما عسكريا مهما كلف بحيث ان كل الدوافع
والاسباب التي غادت لاندلاء هذه الحرب
والمواجهات المسلحه
نتيجه للانسداد في الافق وكذلك نتيجه
لتباعد المواقف السياسيه انا في تقديري
تصريحات بايدن وكذلك الجدار الامريكيه
ستجعل الطرفين يبدون اكثر مرونه فيما
يتعلق بالطاعات فيما الازمه لكن المعارك
العسكريه ستستمر باي حال من الاحوال وانا
في تقدير الازمه الان التي تجري في
السودان يمكن تشبيهها بما حدث في اثيوبيا
بين الحكومه المركزيه وجبهه التحرير
التجاره بالرغم ان الاداره الامريكيه كانت
تضغط وتفعل كل وسائل ضغطه على الجانبين
لكن الحزم العسكري كان له دور كبير جدا في
التوصل الى تفاهمات وتوقيع اتفاقيه في
جنوب افريقيا ولكن الملفت هذه المره في
كلام بايدن ليس فقط ضروره وقف القتال
وتحميل شخصيات مسؤوله
معناها مسؤوليه ما يجري والتهديد
بالعقوبات عندما يقول ان ما يجري في
السودان هو تهديد استثنائي للامن القومي
الامريكي الا يعني هذا مزيد من القوه
في الضغط على الفرقاء
وبلا شك الاحداث التي تحدث في السودان
لديها تداعيات وتاثير كبير جدا على
المنطقه بشكل عام وعلى الامن الامريكي
لاسيما ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بتعتقد ان منطقه
الشرقي افريقيا وكذلك منطقه البحيرات
العظمى وبالاخص القرن الافريقي من مناطق
نفوز المهمه جدا التي لا ترغب في ان
تخسرها لصالح روسيا او احدى القوى
الاقليميه الصاعده سواء كان الصين او بعض
القوى الاخرى ففي تقدير بتزعم بكل ما
اوتيت بقوه وبكل ما اوتيت من النفوس
ووسائل وادوات انها تتدخل لصالح تحقيق
والاستمرار في مصالح الجيوستراتيجيه في
السودان فانا في تقديري ايضا الموقف
الامريكي هذا ربما يدفع احد طرفي الصرع
للارتماء في الحضنه الروسي بشكل مباشر لا
سيما ان هنالك بعض التحذيرات التي صدرت من
صحيفه 24 بوست تحذر بان الدعم السريع هو
الاقرب للتعاون مع روسيا باعتبار ان هنالك
بحضور روسي عن طريق فاجنر وبعض المؤسسات
الرسميه وهنالك تعاون بينهما كبير جدا في
افريقيا فانا في تقديري اذا استمرت
الولايات المتحده في تفعيل هذا السلاح
السلاح العقوبات ربما يجعل التعاون
والحضور الروسي قوي جدا
بدعم واسناد احدى الطرفيه الصرع وهذا
سيعقد المشهد اكثر فاكثر فانا في تقدير
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ربما تناظر
ايضا بهذه الورقه ولا تستخدمها بشكل جدي
او بشكل فاعل باعتبار ان ذلك ايضا سيضع
امام تحدي حقيقه خساره ربما تكون اكبر نعم
عندما نتحدث الان عن المبادرات عمليا هناك
مبادره الايجاد ومبادره سعوديه امريكيه
بشكل خاص نتحدث الان مع المتحدث باسم
الرئيس التنفيذي للايجاد نور محمود الشيخ
من
جيبوتي معنا نساله عن هذه المبادره
للايجاد ما فرص نجاحها
شكرا جزيلا لهذه الدعوه
انا المتحدث الرسمي باسم سكرتاريه
وثمه بالفعل مبادره مرتبطه بالايجاد وقد
رحب بها من قبل جميع الاطراف في جمهوريه
السودان ويتراسها
ثلاثه رؤساء
احدهم ذوباع طويل وهو السيد البكير الذي
يتراس الوساطه هو اسماعيل عمر من جيبوتي
وايضا
رئيس كينيا
وبالتالي هؤلاء الرؤساء الثلاثه تواصلوا
مع
المسؤولين في الخرطوم على نحو يومي
وتواصلوا مع جنرال برهان وجنر الحميتي
وحصل على التزام منهما لتفويض مندوبين له
مالك يخوضوا الحوار يعني هذا تعهد واضح
منهما
نعم نعم انت محق
لقد وفر لنا اشاره مفادها انهما مهتمين
بوضع حد للنزاع لان القتال ليس حلا
والطريقه المثلى تمر من خلال الحوار
واعتقد انهما مقتنعين
مبادره الايجاد الهيئه الحكوميه الدوليه
للتنميه لتلبيه التطلعات شعبي جمهوريه
السودان
وبالتالي اي تظلمات يجب التصدي لها من
خلال الحوار وقد اصرينا على ذلك
بدء الحوار ووضع حد للقتال والوصول الى
وقف الاطلاق النار
ووقفا للاعمال
العدائيه
وجود ايضا ممرات انسانيه لكي نسمح
للدبلوماسي لكي يجلو من المدن السودانيه
والتي يغادر الخرطوم الى مناطق امنه
ومن سوء الطلب لان الحرب مستمره ولكن
مازلنا نستمر في الضغط على القوى
المتناحره لكي تتوقف عن القتال فيما بينها
ولكي تلجا في حوار ونحن مجددا
لنشدد على ان الاطراف وافقت على تفويض
مندوبين لكي
ينطلق الحوار ولكن عدا موضوع وقف القتال
والمساعدات والممرات الامنه هل لديكم تصور
عندما يجلس ممثلات الطرفين
على ماذا سيتفاوضان بالضبط
نعم اقول لسوء الحظ
السودان
يجري فيه قتال بين قوات الدعم السريع
والقوات المسلحه السودانيه وهناك تكلفه
لهذا النزاع ثمه عنف مستشري والقتال ليس
حلا ولم يكن حلا في اي مكان في العالم واي
تظلمات يجب التصدي لها من خلال المفاوضات
والحوار لذلك عندما يصل الى طاوله الحوار
يمكنهم ان يتصدقوا لهذه القضايا
واطلاق
عمليه لوضع حد لهذا النزاع وايضا تلبيه
تطلعات الشعب السوداني اعني بذلك حكومه
يقودها المركب المدني هل معنى ذلك ان
الاجنده مفتوحه وليس لديكم تصور مسبق
للجدول
[موسيقى]
نعم كما تعرفون الميسرون لبناء السلام لا
يرغمون الاطراف على الالتزام ببنود لجدول
اعمال نحن نؤمن ان السودانيين يمكنه ان
يضعوا حلا لي مشاكلهم ولكن يجب ان يتوقف
القتال اولا يجب ان نصل الى وقف للاعمال
العدائيه ويجب على الاطراف ان يصلوا الى
طاوله المفاوضات لكي يتفاوض بشان هذه
القضايا ونحن على ثقه بانها الشعب السودان
يملكون الحل لمشاكلهم ما فرص النجاح في
النهايه الجيش يعتبر حميتي متمرد يجب
القضاء عليه
واحميتي يعتبر ان المشكله في هذا الجيش
ويجب القضاء على البرهان
الذي السجل مبهر فيما يخص
تسهيله مثل هذه العمليات والمفاوضات كما
تعرفون
جبهه تحرير تيجراي والحكومه الاثيوبيه
تقاتل فيما بينهما ولكن في نهايه المطاف
طلبنا منهم ان ياتوا الى طاوله المفاوضات
وبالفعل حصل ذلك وستعرف الاثيوبيون ان
يتفاوضوا للوصول الى حل دائم لذلك
النزاع ووصلوا بالفعل الى وقف للاعمال
العدائيه وما يزال ذلك مستمرا لذلك يمكن
ان ينطبق ذلك على جنوب السودان او بالفعل
انطبق ذلك على جنوب السودان في عام 2018
والاي جاد حاول
ويسر تلك المساله ايضا
ونحن الان نمارس ضغوطات على الاطراف لكي
توقف
تصل الى طاوله المفاوضات ليضعوا لاي
تظلمات يمكن ان تطفو على السطح من خلال
الحوار شكرا جزيلا لك السيد نور محمود
الشيخ المتحدث باسم سكرتيريه الايجاد
متحدثا من جيبوتي شكرا لك
سيد ضياء الدين بلال ما الذي يمكن ان يفهم
من هذا الحديث عن مبادره الايجاد انا
اعتقد انه في سباق للمبادرات وهو وجه من
اولها الازمه كان من المفترض ان يكون
هنالك تنسيق ما بين كل هذه المبادرات
التعامل مع هذه الازمه اعتقد ان التعدد
المبادرات وبهذا الشكل
ستتيح مساحه واسعه للمناوره السياسيه
ولكسب الوقت بالنسبه للطرفين الخاص للجيش
فبالتالي لا اعتقد ان مبادره الايجات لها
ميزه تفضيليه بالعكس الايجاد تاثيره ضعيف
على على الطرفين ربما التاثيرات الاخرى
الامريكيه او السعوديه تصبح
الاكثر فاعليه ليست هنالك مبادره مبادرتين
مبادره الامريكيات هنالك مبادره جزائريه
التي تمثل الجامعه العربيه وهنالك مبادره
اسرائيليه وهنالك مبادره لدول
لدول البحيرات العظمى
نوايا حسنه للتوسط هي عبرت عن نفسها
كمبادرات خاصه فيما يتعلق بالمبادره
الاسرائيليه فاعتقد ان هنالك استشهاد
بالنموذج الاثيوبي والنموذج في جنوب
السودان لم يصل الاطراف الصراع في
الدولتين الى الى الوصول الى التفاوض
والاتفاق الا بعد ان تغيرت معادلات
الميدان لمصلحه طرف في مثل هذه الحاله
التعادليه الى حد لا نستطيع ان نتوقع بان
يميل طرف الان يبدو الدعم السريع لتازم
وضعه العسكري في الميدان هو الاقرب لقبول
واخفي اطلاق النار لانه يريد ان يحافظ على
محقق من مكاسب عسكريه هي محدوده في حد
ذاتها لها رمزيه مثل سيطر سيطرته على على
القصر الجمهوري وعلى الاذاعه وتهديد
للمطار قد يزعم الى تحويل هذه المكاسب
العسكريه
الرمزيه الى الى اجنده سياسيه يجلس بها
للتفاوض لكن الجيش ما لم تكتمل هذه المهمه
العسكريه المتعلقه ليست بانهاء الحرب ككل
ولكن المتعلقه باخلاء الدعم السريع من
الاماكن الاستراتيجيه
وخراج من العاصمه الخرطوم لا اعتقد ان
هنالك استجابه ستحدث وستكون هذه المساحه
مساحه واسعه للمناورات وفي لحظه ما
سيختار الدعم السريع والجيش خيار التفاوض
اما نتيجه للانتصار والشعور بالانتصار
وارتفاع اليد العليا او للشعور بالهزيمه
ومحاوله الخروج باقل بالخصائر التي تحققت
دون الرغبه في تحقيق مكاسب كما المكاسب
التي اعلنت في البدايه والتي حددها الدعم
السريع بالقاء القبض على البرهان وعلى
قياده الجيش والانتقال الى العمليه
السلميه السفير مايكل كارني هل تشاطر وجهه
النظر هذه بمعنى انه مبادره الايجاد وفي
ضوء المقابله التي هن نتابعها قبل قليل لن
تنطلق ولن توضع على السكه الا بعد ان يحقق
طرف على الاقل تفوق نوعي يسمح له بان يبدا
في التفاوض
المباحثات لغايه الان كانت ضبابيه
اود الحديث عن بعض القضايا والمفاهيم
المحدده في هذا الموضوع الامر الاساسي
الذي نحتاج ان ننظر فيه هو تسلسل الاحداث
تسلسل الاحداث التي يمكن ان تفضي الى حل
لهذه المشكله اولها بطبيعه الحال الهدنه
وليس
الهدنه المتقطعه التي شهدناها خلال
ثلاث
سابقه بما في ذلك هنن التي امتدت لسبعه
ايام وفوضت من اجلها الايجاد اذا ما وصلنا
الى هدنه دائمه فان الطرفان العسكريين سوف
يرسل
للمباحثات
والمباحثات يمكن ان تكون طحنا بلا طحين
ولكن يجب ان تتحول الى افعال ما نحتاجه هو
وقف لاطلاق ان وقف منظم لاطلاق النار ويجب
ان يكون هنالك قوه دوليه تفصل بين الطرفين
ويجب ان تكون هنالك بنيه تتصدى للانتهاكات
وتحقق فيها
وتجبرها او تصححها لكي يعود الوضع الى ما
قبل اقتراف الانتهاكات وعندما نصل الى تلك
المرحله يمكن ان نفكر حينها في المفاوضات
الفعليه
احد اوجه فشل السنتين الماضيتين بحسب رايي
هو الفشل في النظر في الشواغل
العسكريه في السودان نعم كانت موجوده في
وثائقها مختلفه
لكنها كانت ثانويه
وكان يمكن التفاوض بشانها بعد الوصول الى
تشكيل حكومه لذلك اعتقد ان هذه الشواغل
العسكريه يجب التصدي لها قبل ان نصل الى
الحكم المدني وهذا ما سمحت لي
ضيفي العزيز يمكنني ان افصل في الامر
قد نعود لهذا التفصيل ولكن سيد محمد طرشين
هل يخشى ان تكون مبادره ايجاد حتى وان
اجتمع
ممثله الطرفين
يعني طحن بلا طحين كما قال السفير
انا في تقديري مبادره الايجاد يمكن ان
تاتي بجديد في حاله استطاعت الدول
الايجارات وكذلك بدعم امريكي انها تطرح
مبدع التنحي وهنا التنحي سواء لمحمد حمدان
دقله وشقيقه وكذلك في الاتجاه الاخر من
قبل القيادات العسكريه حاليا المحسوبه
للجنه الامنيه لنظام عمر البشير ممثله في
عبد الفتاح البرهان وشمس الدين كباشي
وكذلك العطاء وابراهيم جابر فاذا استطاعت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكذلك بعض
الشركاء الاقليميين باعتبار ان هذه الحرب
لديها بعض
الداعمين وكذلك بعض الذين يدعمون الطرفيه
الصراع بشكل او باخر انه قبلوا بفكره
التنحي وتمت ممارسه الضغوط على اطراف
الصرع يمكن ان تاتي بالجديد بحيث انه
مساله الدمج وكذلك مساله قياده سيطره
الدعم السريع يمكن ان تقول للقوات المسلحه
في في طبيعه الصراع هذا او اصل الصراع انا
في تقدير الصراع قائمه على السلطه والثروه
بحيث ان البرهان لديها اطماع وطموح شخصي
يعني يستمروا يستنسخ النموذج اقرب للنموذج
المصري في السودان في الاتجاه الاخر محمد
حمدان دقله يرى انه حان الاوان انه يحكم
ويمثل
شرائح واسعه من ابناء الشعب السوداني ظلت
بعيده من مراكز صنع القرار وكذلك بعيده عن
السلطه والثروه حقا وهذا مدعوم من بعض
القوى الاقليميه وكذلك القوه الدوليه فهذا
معلوم لدينا فبالتالي انا في تقديري اذا
استطاعت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وكذلك
الايجات ان
ترقيم الطرفين في فكره التنحي يمكن ان
يحدث انفراج لكن ما عدا ذلك في ظل وجود
قطبي الصراع ممثلين في البرهان وكذلك محمد
حمدان صعب جدا ان تاتي هذه المبادره بجديد
ما لم يكون هنالك اث او حزم على ارض
المعركه هنالك جزء اخر ما هي اجنده
الحوار او التفاوض بحيث انه هل تكون
مرجعيه هذا التفاوض الاتفاق الاطاري الذي
يعني وصل الانسداد في الافق وهنالك شرائح
واسعه من القوى السياسيه الاساسيه والكتله
الديمقراطيه وكذلك بعض الاطراف التي غير
معنيه بالعمليه السياسيه كالحزب الشيوعي
والحزب البعثه والسودان المستقبل وقطاعات
واسعه ولان المقاومه هل سيكون هذا هو
الاصل اول مرجعيه التي يمكن الاجها لها
الطرفين باعتبار ان الايجارات حتى الان
ليس لديها تصور او رؤيه واضحه في قضايا
الله التفاوض بالنسبه
الامريكيه
السعوديه نريد ان نفصل فيها اكثر ولكن قبل
ذلك هناك معضله اي تسويه تقتضي باما بذهاب
الرجلين
البرهان وحميدتي ولكن غياب حميدتي يعني
انتهاء الدعم السريع بينما ذهاب
البرهان لا يعني ذلك لان في النهايه هناك
المؤسسه العسكريه لكن ايضا اي تسويه تبقي
على الرجلين قد تصبح تسويه مرفوضه لان لا
يمكن للراي العام ان يقبل بقاء رجلين تسبب
في كل هذا الذي يحصل ربما الامر متعلق
بالدعم السريع لانه الدعم السريع لتكوين
عسكري اسري وشخصي خاص بحميته ولكن الجيش
كما انا اعتقد ان كل محاوله لاختزال هذا
الصراع في الاجانب الشخصي ما بين البرهان
وحميدتي انه توصيف خاطي
المشكله مشكله الدعم السريع هي جزء من
التشوهات التي كانت قائمه وجزوا من
الاستفزازات التي كانت موجهه للجيش
كان يتدخل في ادق تفاصيل الجيش كان يقيل
عدد من الضباط يرسل قائمه بقاله عدد من
الضباط في الجيش وفي الشرطه وفي جهاز
الامن كل ذلك من يقاتل حميت الان ولكن
المشكله من سمح له بهذا التغول
البرهان البرهان في النهايه لم يكن يفعل
ذلك رغم رغم انف الجميع البرهان البرهان
لديه معادله خاصه البرهاني يريد ان يحتمل
ان يرقص على راس الثعابين بمعنى انه يخشى
من التكوين الاسلامي داخل الجيش ويخشى
بانه سيكون هدف اذا ابتعد الدعم السريع
واذا ابتعد حمي الدين ويريد ان ان يخيف
الحميدي بالمكونه الاسلامي داخل الجيش فهو
يلعب على هذه التناقضات ومن خلال تعامر
البرهان الان مع الحرب انا نظري ان البره
يزعم لا يزععى للقبالا حمدتي يسعى ليضعاف
حمتي الى اقصى درجه ممكنه حتى يصبح موجود
في المعادله لان غياب حمدي قد يعني
البرهان خروج من الملعب كذلك بالمعادلات
القائمه لذلك يمكن تشبيه حميدتي والبرهان
بانهما اقرب للتوام الملتصق من نواحي
حساسه اي من القلب من الاماكن
المرتبطه بالحياه اي محاولات فصل بين
الاثنين ستنتهي بالقضاء على الاثنين
فبالتالي اعتقد ان المعادله يجب ان اوصفها
فيما يتعلق بالايجاد اعتقد في نقطه مهمه
جدا ربما للجيش حساسيه اتجاه الايجاد
بالنسبه لوجود
الجانب الكيني الجانب الكيني الان يبدو
انه يتحرك بطريقه مستقله عن الايجاد يجتمع
بحمدوك يجتمع بيرسل رسائل سياسيه كما ان
هنالك احاديث كثيره بان للرئيس الكيني
الان علاقات خاصه واستثماريه قيل ذلك
وجنوب السودان وجود الجانب الكيني ربما
يضعف فاعليه المبادره الايجاد في هذه
المعادله بالنسبه للمبادره الامريكيه
السعوديه سفير كارني ما حدودها هي الاخرى
خاصه نريد ان نعرف التوصيف الامريكي لهذا
النزاع قبل قليل ضيفنا من باريس السيد
تورشين اعتبر الصراع صراع على السلطه
والثروه ضيفنا في الاستوديو يعتبر بان من
الخطا ان نصور الامر وكانه صراع بين شخصين
بالنسبه لواشنطن كيف تراها تشخص هذا
الصراع حتى نعرف حضور المبادره
بالفعل هي معركه من اجل السلطه والمال ثمه
عنصر اقتصادي كبير الجيش السوداني القطب
المسلحه السودانيه لديها
الكثير من المصالح
وهنالك ايضا في السودان
مناجموا ذهب وبالتالي فان هنالك شواغل لدى
المؤسسه العسكريه ويجب حلها للوصول الى
مفاوضات نهائيه اما بالنسبه للمبادره
الامريكيه السعوديه
فتقدوا انها سوف تدعم جهود الايجاد
ومفتاح المساله هو ان
المنطقه سوف يتاح لها ممارسه ضغوطات
والوصول الى حل وربما تنظيم
القوى التي سوف تفصل بين الطرفين عندما
يكون هناك اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار
سفير كارني ما نشر عن هذه المبادره يقول
اولا ضمان وقف دائم تحويل الهدنه الى وقت
دائم لاطلاق النار ولكن انشاء فرق فريق
يعالج الجوانب الانسانيه والممرات الامنه
وغير ذلك فريق يتناول موضوع التفاوض بين
الجانبين
ولجنه مشتركه تضم طرفي الصراع
لمراقبه وقف الاعمال العدائيه والقتاليه
كما توصل هل ستكون هذه المهمه سهله
لن تكون المهمه سهله
زملائي وضيوفه وهم محقون عندما قالوا ان
حميتي والبرهان يؤمن بانهما يمكنهما ان
ينتصر واشد على كلمته ينتصر وضعه الكلمه
بين قوسين لانني لا اعتقد ان احدهما كفؤ
عسكريا لكي ينتصر على الاخر لانه ما اظهر
منذ اكتوبر عام 2021 عدم كفاءتهما
للحكم والان يظهرانهما غير كفؤين عسكريه
والنتيجه يجب ان تكون كالتالي يجب ان يجلس
معا لكي يتفاوضات
ويدرج ايضا المكون المدني لكي يصلها الى
حل بشان الشواغل العسكريه والاقتص وقضيه
ايضا الافلات من العقاب والمساءله على
جرائمهم السابقه وانتهاك الانتهاك حقوق
الانسان ولكن المشكله هل المبادره
الامريكيه السعوديه سيد محمد طرشين سيكون
وقعها وادائها وافضل وحظوظها افضل من
مبادره الايجاد
انا اعتقد ذلك بحيث انه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
بحكم حتى الان لم يتم تصنيفها من طرفي
الصراع بانها تنحاس للدعم السريع او
للقوات المسلحه عكس الجانب المصري او
الاماراتي ربما هي محل تقدير الامر الاخر
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تدرك ذلك
تماما وتزعل العمل مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وين اصطحبت بعض دول التريكه
كالمملكه المتحده وكذلك
لكن باي حال من الاحوال
القضيه مرتبطه بالادوات هل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قادرين على استخدام ادوات ناجعه
وفاعله من خلال التوصل الى تفاهمات او
اجبار الطرفين على ذلك انا في تقديري له
بحيث ان حتى الان لم يكن هنالك تصور فيما
يتعلق بالاجنده التفاوضيه ودائما بنقول
الشيطان يكمن في التفاصيل بحيث من الطبيعي
جدا ان يرسل طرفي الصراع مندوبين او
ممثلين
وحتى المؤسسه العسكريه تحدثت بانها لن
تلتقي الدعم السريع في طاوله واحده بمعنى
ان ذلك ستكون المفاوضات بشكل غير مباشر
وبالتالي محتاجه كثير من التنسيق وكثير من
الترتيب من قبل الوسطاء بالتالي هذا من
حيث فكره توقفي اطلاق النار وكذلك مساله
فتح مسارات لادخال المساعدات الطبيه وكذلك
بعض المؤن التي يحتاجها الانسان او
مواطنين الخرطوم فضلا عن ذلك القضيه
الاخرى المهمه انا في تقديري فكره ارسال
مندوبين بعيدين عن الثقل المرتبط بهذه
المجريات او بهذه الاحداث سيجعل الامر
معقد هذا هؤلاء يحتاجون الى مزيد من الوقت
للتشاور للتواصل مع القيادات العسكريه في
الخرطوم فكذلك محتاجين للتواصل مع قياده
الدعم السريع بمعنى مزيد من الوقت
والاستراتيجيه الان التي تتبع القوات
المسلحه هي محاوله كسب الوقت او الشراء
الوقت حتى تحقق مكاسب على ارض الواقع
المؤسسه العسكريه كانت واضحه هنا اسهل سيد
ضياء الدين بلال يعني دفعنا الحاج في
جولته من القيادات العسكريه للجيش في
جولته في السعوديه ومصر اكد ان هذا
الموضوع لن يتم الا بالحسم العسكري هناك
تمرد ويجب القضاء عليه اذا كان هذا هو
التصور السائد لدى المؤسسه العسكريه
بمجملها يعني الحديث عن جلوس ممثلين او
وفدي تفاوض سواء في مبادره الايجاد او
المبادره الامريكيه السعوديه مثلا غير
وارده الجيش حصر هذا هذا التفاوض او هذا
التشاور حول الجوانب الانسانيه الهدم
ولكن لا اتفاق نهائي خاصه واعتقد ان الان
بمعطيات ما حدث لو وصل وصلت الاطراف
لاتفاق حول اخلاء الاماكن الاستراتيجيه
وسط الخرطوم من القوات العسكريه
ربما فتح ذلك طريقا للحل اعتقد ان الازمه
الاساسيه ان هذا التفاوض والاحاديث عنه
يتم تحت سيطره الدعم السريع وتاثيره على
هذه المنطقه الحيويه الجيش ربما ادى ما
اراد فيما يتعلق
القبائل على القوه العسكريه الصلبه
بالنسبه للدعم السريع واصبحت هنالك قوه
اقل وبامكانه اتخاذ تدابير في الجانب
الاقتصادي اذا اذا اله الاوضاع الجيش لم
يسقط وظل مسيطر على الحكم اعتقد ان ذلك
سيجرد حميدتين من كثير من
الامتيازات في جانب اخر فيما يتعلق
بالمجتمع الدولي لا نحتقد ان المجتمع
الدولي اسهم اسهاما كبيرا في تزكيه هذه
النيران بسوء المعالجات والمقترحات التي
كانت تقدم بالاتفاق الاطار الذي اراد ان
يفصل الدعم السريع عن قياده الجيش ويربطه
بتكونات سياسيه ارادت للدعم السريع ان
يصبح الزراع عسكري لها
الاتفاق الايطالي عندما يتحدث البعض الان
عن الاتفاق الايطالي هل هذا كلام معقول هل
بعد كل هذا الذي جرى سنعود مره اخرى
لاتفاق الاطار هل هذا وارد هو الاتفاق
الاتفاق الايطالي هو الذي اشعل هذه
التناقضات وهو الذي لعدم وعي وادرهاك
المجتمع الدولي على اطراف الدوليه
لتحقيقات لتعقيدات المشهد السياسي
والعسكري السوداني قدمت معالجات هي التي
اشعلت الحريق المجتمع الدولي لا يدرك هذه
هذه التعقيدات التفصيليه ما كانت ما هي
المهمه الموكله للمبعوث البئسه الامميه
انها تساعد على الانتقال وترتب الاوضاع
الى الانتخابات وتعين السودان في جوانب
الانسانيه هي فشلت في كل ما حدد لها
فبالتالي اعتقد ان المجتمع الدولي الان هو
السبب الاكبر في اشتعال هذه التناقضات وفي
وصول الاحداث الى وصلت اليه سنقوم في
نهايه هذه الحلقه بجوله سريعه بين ضيوفنا
بشكل جدا عما اذا كانوا يعتقدون فعلا
بامكانيه تسويه في القريب نبدا بالسفير
كانوا ثم السيد ترشين ثم ننهي بضيفنا
السيد بلال في الاستوديو تفضل السفير
كارني
بالفعل
[موسيقى]
ليس ثمه طريقه اخرى
بخلاف بدء المباحثات التي تفضي الى وقف
لاطلاق النار
وصولا الى المفاوضات ووجود مراقبيه دوليين
وادراج المدنيين يجب ان نتصدى
لشغلين الاساسين العسكريين
المسائله والافلات من العقاب وعندما نصل
الى اتفاق يمكن الوصول الى اتفاق لدمج
القوتين تحت مظله جيش وطني موحد عندها
الجنر الحميتي والجنرال البرهان يمكن
بالفعل ان ينظر في التقاعد
ووصولا الى الحكم المدني في السودان سيد
طرشين
انا اتوقع للاسف الشديد ان يطال امد الحرب
لفتره طويله جدا وفي نهايه المطاف ستكون
هنالك مفاوضات وينبغي ان تكون هذه
المفاوضات بضروره تنحي الجنرلين محمد
حمدان وكذلك عبد الفتاح البرهان وينبغي ان
تكون معالم دمج الدعم السريع في الجيش
السوداني وكذلك كل حركات الكفاح المسلح في
قيد زمني معلوم حتى تكون الفتره
الانتقاليه فتره قصيره لا تتجاوز العامل
ومن بعد تكون هنالك انتخابات حره ونزيهه
وهذا هو المدخل الحقيقي لاستقمال مسار
الانتقال المدني الديمقراطي ومن خلال هذه
الحكومه المنتخبه يمكن ان تحدث اصلاحات
جذريه في كل مؤسسات الدوله بما في ذلك
المؤسسه العسكريه بدءا من شروط دخول
الكليه الحربيه والترقيات وما الى ذلك اي
ترويج بان الدعم السريع يمكن ان ياتي
بالديمقراطيه فهذا وهم
نعم سيد بلال بكل الممرات والماسي التي
حدثت تعتقد ان يمكن ان تؤدي هذه الحرب الى
انهاء حاله التشوهات القائمه خاصه
التشوهات العسكريه وان تخترب اكثر
بالاطراف الى العمليه هي اطراف العمليه
السياسيه للانتخابات اعتقد ان جزءا اساسيا
من الازمه الان هو تمدد واستطاله الفتره
الانتقاليه ومحاوله الاطراف المختلفه
العسكريه والسياسيه للاستثمار في هذه
المساحه لمصلحه الخاصه لو اقتربنا اكثر من
صناديق الاختراع لا اعتقد ان للصناديق
الذخيره سيكون لها دور في الفتره القادمه
لو قلنا في النهايه ان اي تفاوض يجب ان
يكون الهدف هو منع السودان من التفكك ومن
الدخول في فوضى اذا توصلنا الى ذلك فهو
نهايه هذا انجاز كبير اذا تحقق ذلك ولكن
المشكله الاساسيه هي التدخل الاصابع
الاصابع الاقليميه والاصابع الدوليه التي
لها اجند عابره للحدود تحاول ان تؤثر
وتجير الاوضاع في السودان لمصلحتها شكرا
جزيلا لك سيد ضياء الدين بلال ضيفنا في
شكرا لك ايضا محمد من باريس والسفير مايكل
كارني من واشنطن
دمتم في رعايه الله والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]